When I was 27 years old,...
...I left a very demanding job in management consulting...
...for a job that was even more demanding: teaching.
I went to teach seventh graders math in the New York City public schools.
And like any teacher, I made quizzes and tests.
I gave out homework assignments.
When the work came back, I calculated grades.
What struck me was that IQ was not the only difference between my best and my worst students.
Some of my strongest performers did not have stratospheric IQ scores.
Some of my smartest kids weren't doing so well.
And that got me thinking.
The kinds of things you need to learn in seventh grade math,...
...sure, they're hard: ratios, decimals, the area of a parallelogram.
But these concepts are not impossible,...
...and I was firmly convinced that every one of my students could learn the material...
...if they worked hard and long enough.
After several more years of teaching,...
...I came to the conclusion that what we need in education...
...is a much better understanding of students and learning from a motivational perspective,...
...from a psychological perspective.
In education, the one thing we know how to measure best is IQ.
But what if doing well in school and in life...
...depends on much more than your ability to learn quickly and easily?
So I left the classroom, and I went to graduate school to become a psychologist.
I started studying kids and adults in all kinds of super challenging settings,
...and in every study my question was, who is successful here and why?